i saw a video of you with with jay-z
working on 99 problems where you
suggested acapella
opening the uh the song with acapella
just no instruments just voice
that to me
i mean that's one of the characteristics
of the things
uh of the ways you've brought out the
best in artists is doing less sort of
tending towards simplicity in some kind
of way
so that that that choice of acapella is
really interesting because like i could
see a lot of people think that that's a
bad idea
but it turned out to be a really
powerful idea can you maybe talk about
the simplicity
how to find simplicity why you find
simplicities beautiful it does appear to
be beautiful
what is that yeah i i don't know where
it comes from it it has been with me
from the beginning of my work the very
first
album i ever produced
the credit i took was reduced by me
instead of produced by me
um for that reason like i i like the
idea of getting to the essential and i
i have a better idea now
that i've done it for a while but at the
time it was purely an instinctual
thing and
part of it is a sonic there's a sonic
benefit
which is
the less elements you have
uh you can hear each of the ones that
are there and they can sound better
and the less there are the more um the
more space they could have around them
and the more you can hear their
personality if you would record
10 people playing the same guitar part
and you listen to it it would sound like
guitar
and if you play record one person
playing a guitar part
it sounds like a person playing the
guitar
it's different than just guitar
and the
often in the studio the idea of building
upon things and adding adding layers to
thicken to make it sound bigger
sometimes
the more things you add the smaller it
gets
so it's a it's a
a lot of it is counterintuitive until
you just didn't practice see what
what works try it so try removing stuff
until it's just right it's the einstein
thing make it
uh
make it as simple as possible but not
simpler
that's such a
fun like finding a stopping place just
keep chopping away
and chopping away yeah there's something
we we also like to do called the
ruthless edit which is let's say you're
at a point where
it can work for anything but i'll give
you the example with an album
um
we've recorded
25 songs
we think the album is going to have 10.
instead of picking our favorite 10
we limit it to what are the five or six
that we can't live without
so going past
even the goal
to get to the real like heart of it and
then see okay we have these five or six
that we can't live without
now
what would we add to that
that makes it better and not worse
and um
it's just it it puts you in a different
frame
when you start with
building instead of removing and you
might find that there's nothing you need
to add
sometimes
sometimes something happens when you get
to the real essence
then when you start adding things back
it becomes clear that
it was just supposed to be this
this tight little thing
you